in 2007 Sony released the Nick Cage
superhero flick Ghost Rider which was
both sookie and cheesy and equal measure
and in 2012 it got a sequel ghostwriter
spirit of vengeance but since the rights
to Ghost Rider have reverted to Marvel
there has been no sign of a third movie
ever happening here is why Marvel won't
give Ghost Rider another movie box
office mess slava first Ghost Rider film
earned a decent two hundred and twenty
eight million dollars worldwide the
second only managed 132 million dollars
which is less than Tony Stark carries in
his wallet for petty cash big man in a
suit of armor take that off what are you
genius billionaire playboy
philanthropist considering both films
were also lambasted by movie critics
there's not much reason for Marvel to
put out another Ghost Rider film when
they have proven properties like Captain
America and spider-man to focus on
instead
not to mention new franchises like
Captain Marvel and black panther Nic
Cage isn't interested even if the stars
somehow aligned and Marvel did decide to
tackle a third Ghost Rider film with
Cage the actor has indicated he's not
really all that keen to climb back on
the motorcycle given the chance as he
told Collider close I've said what I
have to say I don't want to say never
anything's possible but I doubt highly
that I would be in a third installment
of that we're guessing most fans aren't
exactly disappointed with that news
television though he's not on the big
screen anymore there are still some
Ghost Rider stories being told in
live-action they're just happening on
Marvel's agents of shield series yokas
decide who deserves to die
I'm not the one who decides the newest
ghostwriter Robbie Reyes is played by
Gabriel Luna and has quickly become a
fan favorite though ratings are down the
introduction of Ghost Rider has
revitalized the show providing a
connection to the mystical side of the
MCU opened up by the big screen his
Doctor Strange team up anyone Marvel's
Great Divide fans hoping that Robbie
Reyes his appearance in agents of shield
might be planting the seeds for the
newest Ghost Rider to jump onto the big
screen are probably going to be
disappointed
he made a deal with the devil his notice
you know the rationalists in me wants to
agree but go on fire presents a pretty
compelling argument for hail Satan so
far the events in the movies have had
only a minor effect on the television
series while the stuff on the TV shows
hasn't even been mentioned in the movies
I guess you guys haven't heard about me
this is probably because of a
long-running power struggle between
movie studio head Kevin Feige and Marvel
president Ike Perlmutter who is still in
charge of the TV shows as long as there
continues to be backstage drama between
the two Ghost Rider is probably stuck
where he is on television and not in the
movie Johnny Blaze is old news
the version of Ghost Rider that Nick
Cage played Johnny Blaze seems to just
be part of the current Ghost Rider's
backstory in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe though Cage himself didn't
appear on agents of shield the origin
story for Robby Reyes involves Robbie
making a deal with the devil in order to
save his brother's life you're right
it's someone there when I came to but it
wasn't a good
the devil add in the fact that the show
also sees Clinton carnival the carnival
that Johnny Blaze works for and it seems
as though Johnny story is just prologue
in the MCU of course Marvel could always
do a prequel series about Johnny's time
as ghost writer but we sort of already
have that in the form of sony to film
no more crap the first Ghost Rider movie
hit just before the comic book movie
creative Renaissance of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe back when Studios
could still get away with releasing
mediocre comic book adaptations in terms
of quality and tone the ghost writer
films have far more in common with last
generation superhero movies like
daredevil and Fantastic Four than they
do with modern films like Iron Man or
The Dark Knight
given the poor reputation the ghost
writer films have is unlikely Marvel
would risk changing their perfect record
as a box office with a franchise that
carries so much baggage thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to